hello below where Joelle and Claudia
from Mexico from the Yucatan Peninsula
we're at salsa sea palace which is a
UNESCO World Heritage Site and we're
going to take a look at the park we
stopped at deutsche welle was holding a
photo competition of people at unesco
world heritage sites around the world
and we just taken a picture of ourselves
at Chichen Itza in front of the pyramid
and my husband said why don't we send it
in mungus when we uploaded it and after
just a few days we got an email saying
we'd won that's why we're here and we're
really enjoying ourselves it's a
glorious day cs50 says I shouldn't come
off the attack
section
as a quiz I see because we met at a
diving center not long after I'd left
Germany and we've been together for 12
years salmon a Mayan shaymin married us
in 2006 and we're really happy I'm five
months pregnant and we're expecting a
little mayan princess around new years
eve shanna maya princess in anza vista
you
see citizen look those are all mythical
creatures they're half horse and half
human head fits holiday season yeah Tyga
I know it's really impressive where we
come from there are also lots of unesco
world heritage sites and it's wonderful
that people are trying to preserve them
for our descendants for Humanity
ohit's safaga view there's still the
question of how they made that turquoise
color because to this day it's not clear
how the Mayans made it either
watch anyways BRB 10 why is awesome
this is fast me in the car leaving it's
almost like the Caribbean a bit cooler
but great for laxing after a day like
we've had
it's a woman it was wonderful to be here
in Berlin and pots dumb and to see these
gorgeous UNESCO World Heritage Sites we
hope we can come again soon bye bye on
some cheese sauce